we have a voicemail number 2192 David P
uh Trump's performance on Saturday at
his rally was so bad that I got way more
people angry with me for my coverage of
the rally than normal here's one example
David pack and this is your only friend
from Cleveland Ohio conservative okay
responding to your pathetic
performance last night did you
get a pink slip for your performance
last night
no I mean I'm in charge who's gonna fire
me you're watching Trump at your whim
is that what liberals find entertaining
seriously did you earn a paycheck for
that yes you know David Trump's rallies
are censored
and no they're not Trump's rallies are
not censored
um our limited have limited exposure
because of big Tech censorship
that's completely untrue all sorts of
right-wing YouTube channels and Facebook
pages streamed the rally live and had
hundreds of thousands of viewers because
they fear the truth and that's why I got
stuck with you
and realize that what a classless
Shameless ignorant Liberal Liberal you
are yeah anyway he goes on for two more
minutes but the worse Trump's
performances are the more messages like
that I get really uh really quite a
trend that we see we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
who would stay and fight if Russia
invaded the U.S there's a new poll
and much much more sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access to
the world famous bonus show much hated
by Alex Jones oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad uh I will see you on the bonus show
thank you Alex